Blower dere,
what the heck, why are
you talking about medicine again?
Misfortune to live
I didn't want you to bear
it I thought of you so I tried to adopt
me Misfortune to live as a magician
Why is it unfortunate enough for those who
are powerless  Well,
if you use your power to carry this house on your back, you'll reveal it to the public Your
nails are powerless as a magician, and
you'll continue to feel an inferiority complex.  Well, I wish I could learn about Papa's fruitfulness It's a
world day when most of the magical
power has been lost But, haha, but are you saying that I'm not strong enough
?  No
matter how much I
try, I can't succeed Why should I not have done [music] I'm so sorry
[music]